[Música]
cuando tenía 16 años de edad sin haberlo
planeado protagonizó una película
peruana
retablo
una película habla de un 90% que hecho
en la cual divida a segundo
no sé si alguno de ustedes puedo verlo
el retablo cuenta la historia del
segundo paucar un adolescente ayacuchano
que quiere ser un maestro está lista
como su padre a quien admira y de quien
aprende este hermoso arte con mucho
entusiasmo para así poder continuar con
el legado familiar
camino a la ciudad para entregar unos
pedidos segundo observa casi por
accidente a su padre en un acto que hace
que todo su mundo se le venga abajo en
un entorno muy conservador segundo
tratará de convivir en silencio con todo
lo que le sucede para así poder
reconstruir su propio retablo familiar y
encontrar su camino quizás se pregunten
por qué el nombre de la película de
retablo el retablo es una artesanía
folclórica de ciertas zonas andinas del
perú que con figuras hechas de yo soy
papá representan escenas cotidianas y
religiosas dentro una caja de madera en
la película se utilizó principalmente
como una metáfora para contar la
historia y aquí segundo atraviesa
diferentes situaciones atraviesa
diferentes retablos para poder encontrar
su camino
y protagonizar esta película
represento un verdadero desafío para mí
y todavía peor sin haber estudiado
actuación
y quiero aprovechar este espacio para
contarles mi historia detrás de la tabla
nací en el legendario distrito los
morochucos de pampa cangallo un pueblito
aya escuchando en asia la del perú desde
muy niño por influencia de mis padres
siempre he participado en diferentes
actividades en mi colegio y en mi
comunidad tanto en lo académico como en
el deporte y el arte y como parte de mi
formación siempre he tratado de dar lo
mejor de mí poner el alma y el corazón
cuando tenía 15 años me mudé con mi
familia a la ciudad de huamanga
donde continuar mis estudios en la gran
unidad escolar mariscal cáceres
en una clase de biología entraron a mi
salón dos gringos así le decimos a lo
que son el imán
dijeron que estaban buscando chicos que
quisieran pasar por un casting para un
papel en una película con varios de mis
compañeros empezaron a levantar la mano
al verlos
yo también levanté la mía y dije yo
también me apunto
y ahí fue donde empezó todo
llegué a casa con miedo asustado porque
no sabía en que me había metido
le dije a mi mamá mamá algo terrible me
ha pasado mi mamá se asustó y me dijo
qué pasó te has peleado moviendo la
cabeza le dije que no y le di el
papelito del castell me miró y sonrió
sonrió como diciendo acaso este es algo
terrible juniors
la conversión quedó ahí después donde
volvimos a mencionar nada acerca del
castro hasta que llegó el día era un
sábado recuerdo a las 10 de la mañana yo
no quería ir estaba nervioso tenía miedo
tenía ese temor de entrar en lo
desconocido de entrar en tierras
extrañas
mi mamá insistió en que vaya ya había
asumido un compromiso así que fuimos
llegamos y entramos en una sala con un
papelito en la puerta que decía casting
película retablo al entrar encontramos
chicos concentrándose y esperando su
turno se escuchaban gritos pasos y
respiraciones en un salón al lado de la
sala
de pronto ya era hora mi turno había
llegado
pase al gran salón
pase únicamente sabiendo que lo que iba
a hacer ahí lo haría de la mejor manera
posible daría todo de mí y así fue
unas semanas después llamaron a casa
para decir que había pasado a la segunda
y última audición a esta última edición
fui solo fui solo pero con muchísima
seguridad
después de ello por alguna razón ya
sabía que iba a ser elegido no sé por
qué pero ya lo sabía y que creen
efectivamente otro par de semanas
después llamaron a casa y dijeron que yo
había sido elegido
felicidades juniors ha sido elegido en
ese momento a pesar de que personas
cercanas a mi familia estaban
emocionados por lo que iba a venir
yo sentí miedo porque era un mundo
totalmente desconocido
a pesar del miedo
acepte entrar a ese mundo me arriesgue
me tiré a la piscina
creo que influyó también mi pasión por
el arte en sí ya que vengo de una
familia de músicos y mi familia como
siempre me apoyó en esta decisión y me
sentí protegido pero en algún momento
del camino era solo yo tenía que
enfrentarme al proceso de preparación en
ese momento encontré en el maravilloso
equipo humano del retablo una familia
una familia en la cual podía confiar y
sentirme también protegido y realmente
éramos una familia
todos ellos fueron parte importante para
mí en el proceso de preparación y el
rodaje
encontré gente muy comprometida gente
muy generosa y muy muy comprometida con
el proyecto y eso a mí me encantó
después después de ello empezamos con mi
iniciación actoral durante mis
vacaciones con muchas reuniones para
leer el guión entender la historia
encontrar la esencia de la historia y
también encontrar cosas en común yo
entre pse entre junior y segundo mi
personaje
después de este proceso después de esta
iniciación tuve que aprenderás el arte
de hacer un retablo
así que asistí a clases con el maestro
de turista julio urbano creo que es el
último un maestro que queda de su
generación a él le encanta la
puntualidad lo sé porque un par de
decisión tarde
aprendí muchísimo de él aprendí a
preparar la masa para dar para dar vida
a los muñequitos a moldear los a
construir la caja del retablo y mi parte
favorita a pintar a darle color a darle
vida al retablo
como una prueba final yo tenía que
elaborar mi propio retablo
elegí hacer un nacimiento
después de este proceso tenía que
encontrar gente que me pueda ayudar
y aceptable lo encontré
todo el equipo aportó muchísimo aprendí
mucho de todos sobre todo del director
de la película álvaro de mis compañeros
actores a mí el callo que hace mi papá
magaly solier que hace de mi mamá en la
película
álvaro el director fue mi guía para
darle vida a segundo
me enseñaba a jugar con mis emociones a
imaginar situaciones que jamás me habían
ocurrido como juniors a sentir lo que
sentiría el personaje en ese momento y
expresarlas como si realmente estuviesen
pasando a respetar y entender al
personaje a entrar en la piel del
segundo ya salir de
con damián y magaly tuvimos el reto de
interpretar a una familia en este
proceso encontramos en el quechua
nuestra lengua materna una fortaleza la
cual nos nos ayudó a conectarnos
fácilmente y crear ese clima familiar
así como según dice papá tiene una
relación muy cercana yo forme esa
relación con la miel él y yo nos
volvimos tan amigos tan cercanos hasta
el punto de que me acompañaba a casa a
visitar a mis a mis papás y en mis
hermanos
y nos compenetramos tanto que había
momentos en los cuales nuestros pasos se
sincronizaban sin que nos diéramos
cuenta en los muchos paseos que dábamos
con el equipo logramos generar una
relación familiar de confianza cariño y
amistad recuerdo un día que hubo un
accidente un camión del equipo que él se
cayó no mismo
cuando me enteré esto me angustia mucho
pues el conductor del vehículo luchito
era ya más o menos una personalidad para
a mí me hacía recordar mucho a mi
abuelito felizmente no ocurrió en
ninguna desgracia el camión cayó solo
sin pasajeros y no saben cuán grande fue
mi alegría al ver a luchito y les corrí
con todas mis fuerzas y lo abrace con
todas mis fuerzas esta preocupación de
todos por todos es también lo que más
rescato muchas veces nos enfocamos en
los actores o en el director y no vemos
lo que hay detrás a un equipo humano
comprometido con dar todo de sí para
poder lograr una meta en común
un equipo tan alineado se convierte en
una familia que da resultados especiales
retablo ha ganado 32 premios en todo el
mundo y quizás sea una de las películas
peruanas más galardonadas de la última
década
lo cual me hace sentir muy feliz y
orgulloso pero a mi protagonista de esta
película me costó bastante pues cuando
cuando protagoniza esta película cuando
empezamos con el rodaje y la preparación
estaba en el colegio
pero yo necesitaba su preparación sabía
que necesita esa preparación para
interpretar lo mejor posible a mi
personaje y así que tuve que esforzarme
muchísimo más
mis clases eran desde las siete y cuarto
de la mañana hasta la una y media de la
tarde
salía del colegio me recogían nos íbamos
a almorzar y luego de ello empezábamos
con los ensayos
ensayábamos y ensayábamos hasta las ocho
nueve de la noche después de ello
llegaba a casa agotado con ganas de
descansar pero no tenía que seguir ya
que me quedaba en las tareas trabajos y
exposiciones del colegio
rosas y hasta la 12 de la madrugada y
así era mi vida de lunes a viernes y los
sábados y domingos era un peor ensayaba
y ensayaba todo el día fueron más de
tres meses de preparación pero valió la
pena valió la pena porque al momento de
la filmación me adapté fácilmente y
tenía muchísima confianza en mí y
gracias también a este esfuerzo fui
nominado al mejor actor joven en el
festival de cine
palm springs en eeuu y recibir las
felicitaciones de muchos críticos de
cine en todo el mundo pero más allá de
aprender a actuar de la fama y los
reconocimientos retablo me permitió ver
el mundo más allá de mi perspectiva a
darme cuenta de que soy capaz de
intentar y lograr cosas
recuerdan que hace unos minutos les dije
que al principio tenía miedo
pues esa decisión de alegar me me
abrieron todas esas puertas
y puedo hoy estar parado aquí frente a
ustedes y decirles arriesguen se tienen
se la piscina sino si desean es posible
que no pase nada pero si se arriesgan
créanme van a pasar cosas
y entreguen todo de sí al margen de los
resultados y quién sabe
que se pueden encontrar con un mundo
lleno de oportunidades y posibilidades
que como yo no se imaginaban no tengan
miedo al fracaso solo asegúrense de
poner el alma y el corazón
[Aplausos]
[Música]